foxsports1 NFL college football analyst
and also gentleman who's gonna be
calling some games to the pac-12 network
good to see you Ryan Leaf once again yes
sir thank you you bet um so let's just
jump right into it I saw a couple tweets
that you you had on the news that came
out of Ohio State yesterday that Urban
Meyer is getting a three-game suspension
Jean Smith is getting a 2-week
suspension and other than the report for
all of us to digest the page will be
turned there in Columbus what are your
thoughts last night it was yeah I was
difficult last night I don't for
somebody who let's put it this way I
have a unique perspective on it the fact
that I was a college coach and I messed
up and I found a way to deal with the
consequences and be better but I've been
asked the question lately like if
somebody offered me a coaching job again
would I take it and I my answer is I
don't know if I deserve it right I don't
know if a parent could trust me with
their child because of my past mistakes
and those are consequences to that
coaching in college is not a it's not a
right you know it's a privilege and I'm
not really the the investigation and
everything that comes out with I'm not
necessarily too involved with that but
what what the program stood for what
they said it stood for was a marketing
campaign essentially it wasn't what he
believed because he stepped up on Big
Ten media day simply told the world a
lie and hey coach is live the media all
the time it was what it was about that
he lied about it's the problem for me
and essentially he told all those kids
he coaches that it's okay to lie because
he'll just get a slap on the wrist and
essentially he victim shamed and for me
those two things don't compute now what
I hoped would have happened is that is
that and I made this clear to Ohio State
fans you're gonna you you're gonna be
okay if bourbon Meyers not your head
coach it just proved to everybody then
they have the opportunity to be better
during this whole process and they
weren't and that's the troubling part of
it to your point they they flip the page
I think Urban Meyer's answer to all
these questions that come up the neck
few weeks are too simple you know the
school made their decision I sat out
three weeks
oh yeah that's what's gonna be right I
mean there's unless he decides to do a B
and unless he does to decide that there
is some sort of PR work on his part that
needs to be done for himself whether
somebody sits him down and explains to
him this is what's happening that if he
does not want to coach much longer for
whatever reason does want a job in the
media afterwards and needs to reburn
--is-- his credentials on that front
that he sits down and as a one-on-one
with some potentially friendly face the
other than that the question anybody
asked him a question he'll be like
that's already done I served my time
asked and answered next question yep and
that's and the hardest thing to kind of
take in from all this and it just proves
to the point of why I like a journey a
jury of your peers doesn't mean people
who benefit from you staying in place
right the people that adjudicated this
process were individuals that benefited
with Urban Meyer staying on in his job
that's not an unbiased investigation I
mean you read the investigation stuff I
did I read recovered his cover this was
not presented to the media either before
the press conference do you think the
media would have had some sort of
question here and there on what was
presented in that investigation that was
left till after he made the statement
this was a big thing so when I yelled at
the reporter that was kind of what went
viral 20 years ago
I I stood up the next day and gave an
apology or what was a written apology
and when I watched the press conference
last night I it was like I use this I
use this analogy a lot when I see people
behaving in the same form that I have in
my life I say like oh it looked like I
was looking in the mirror because if you
watch there's just so much unemotional
when I'm giving this statement and I
just kind of discard the paper into my
locker I just thought to myself in that
moment that that's me at 21 years old
simply not taking any accountability for
what I just did the day before and it it
opens your eyes to these these things
when it happens it makes you
truly confront what you have been like
and then go why I can t see that either
wasn't he not prepared for this process
that was about to happen Lester last
night I these are all good questions I
don't you know I've spent the last month
trying to be somebody who can get inside
Urban Meyer's head and what he's
thinking and how he goes about his
business and whether he feels that he
should be accountable to anybody other
than the fan base that he says that he's
let down I honestly don't know how to
answer all that but one thing I do want
to touch upon a little bit more of what
you've just said over the last few
minutes Ryan Leaf here on the Rich Eisen
show is putting yourself in the shoes of
Zach Smith so you've been there is what
you're saying well I think that anytime
somebody acts out behaviorally I think
that you you develop some sort of
empathy and when I talk to these college
kids I talked to him about the
difference between empathy and sympathy
right sympathy is you feel sorry for
somebody empathise you actually put
yourself in their shoes and experience
what they're feeling right and yesterday
when when Urban Meyer was giving that
speech or or reading that statement I
was like I could put myself in his shoes
and know exactly where he was at that
moment and and you have to take that all
in and then and then not necessarily
pass judgment on it but understand that
that that you know what he's going
through and he just isn't aware there's
no self awareness around it
right but in terms of Zach Smith there's
some of the behavior that's described
here for outside of what was going on
with his wife is completely out of
control
yeah fact that he had a job how did how
was that happen I mean how does he
continue to have a job in that position
it that's what that's to hearing what
the investigation brought to form is
makes me even wonder more why why
continuously it happened over and over
and over again that's a big reason why
everybody still wondering why herb Meyer
didn't do anything firt didn't do
anything before well I'm assuming the
coach who you were coaching for you you
you weren't the grandson of his mentor I
was I was removed from my my job
immediately soon as the head coach found
out I was asked to resign well I never
there
that urban didn't know about the
photographs in the White House didn't
know what was going on with the
secretary didn't know but Brett McMurphy
who's been who's reporting has been at
the forefront of all of us said that
definitely staff at the Ohio State knew
that that is that is the cop-out it is
did other members of the staff of the
witch football program was West Texas
A&M okay in college and yeah I mean the
the the it wasn't a joke the the
constant was that if you got injured
coach leaf would would come come see you
essentially and and take advantage of
him by asking them for their pain pills
or ultimately at the end you know just
taking them from him from the player so
it was known the head coach clearly
didn't know until it was presented to
him and immediately I was asked to
resign so I have the understanding I
don't let's look at this way
consequences are deserving of what
behavior is exhibited I go to the Ray
Rice incident right it's a privilege to
play pro football I know that and it's
it's not a right and there were
consequences to his actions now what he
did with that and what we's doing now
with it he's out there raising awareness
he's trying to be a better man he's
speaking about it that was the change
and I talked about this when this first
initially happened with an herb admirer
I said that he is going to either get a
become a better person when he loses his
job cuz I thought he was gonna lose his
job from when this first came out and I
said he can take this have an
understanding and be better about it and
become a better man because he didn't
act accordingly like he was supposed to
and all I feel like you Ohio State did
in this moment is just enable his
behavior I surrounded myself with people
like that my whole life right that just
told me I was the victim that it wasn't
my fault but the people who really care
about me and who really unconditionally
loved me like showed me that mirror
showed me when I was behaving that way
and that was the only way I could make a
change in myself otherwise I was just
gonna continue to act out and behave the
same way my whole life Ryan Leaf here
and the Rich Eisen should take a
60-second break come back set up the
pac-12 season that you're gonna be
calling some games for pac-12 and also
pac-12 network and also you have a ganda
to a
ton of schools at Chris Peterson of
Washington here having a cougar into his
myths to talk to his Huskies I would
love to know what your what your telling
these kids when you see him back in 60
seconds with Ryan Leaf here on the Rich
Eisen show alright welcome back to the
show Ryan Leaf is here so we had a Chris
Peterson of Washington on the show and
he's like I had Ryan Leaf in to talk to
the kids and obviously I know what your
message is and some fans who don't I'm
about to hear it my first thought was
what but yeah like Washington State's
Ryan Leaf here in Washington and he said
it was great he said it was awesome
having you there it was difficult to be
there but I think that I mean the
message is so much more important than
any rivalry because and it was emotional
for whatever reason there's there's been
something that I've added to the speech
about you know seeing the quarterback
starting quarterback for my alma mater
take his life and I expressed to them in
that moment that if you need to use
somebody if you need to ask for help you
can use me and that that crosses every
every line you can imagine when it comes
to rivalry and sure and everything like
that so it's been really impacted for me
Nick Saban was the first coach to reach
out last year and I think that tells you
a lot coming from the five-time national
champion did you know he was calling did
George your phone just go off hey hey
Ron well you had it
he had his uh he had his chief
operations guy Ellis called me mm-hmm
he had seen the ESPN documentary that
Tim Tom Rinaldi had done yes and sure
enough he had me out first one to have
me out and then as soon as that happens
all sudden his coaching tree of course
and got very smart and Jimbo Fisher and
everybody whose coach Dundrum goes oh
this is what NICs doing okay so then my
phone starts to ring more and then this
year I traveled around and hit up about
eight eight football teams this this
fall so is that how Lane Kiffin I
believe so
from Saban I believe so I think they all
stand up to come from that I also think
Ryan Holliday who wrote the book ego is
ego is the enemy mm-hmm
and helped help you know I guess geese
grease those skids a little bit too and
so again what is your message that
you're telling these it's just pretty
much my story I don't necessarily go in
there and tell them what to do or what
not to do but I think a lot of people
assume it's about you know how not to do
something or or about my substance abuse
problems but it really it's about choice
and it's about entitlement it's about
understanding that there are different
things that that makes success and it's
not money power and prestige you know
it's about accountability and choices
and that's that's essentially what it is
and hopefully there's an impact and I
can't control what they do with the
message I find that there are plenty of
great messengers out there right now I
followed in a couple of venues I
followed Rachel Barbeau who started this
program called changing the narrative
and Brenda Tracy who's been working the
the program set the expectation really
impressive young women and are doing a
tremendous job and I just kind of come
in from the other side of things they
come in from the victims side of things
I come in from the side of essentially
the entitled athlete and how that just
and I tell those guys I look him right
in the face and I say I'm exactly you're
sitting exactly where I was and I got to
accomplish everything you want to
accomplish and I still lost it all
because of my lack of ability to deal
with life on life's terms and that's
usually how the the story starts coaches
have been really really welcoming I'm
gonna do some extra work with Texas A&M
and Jimbo Fisher and that staff this
this season I'm actually gonna go and go
with them to the Alabama game geez
so you know this is this is great for me
because football is such an important
part of my life it gave me everything it
was a toxic thing for me for a long time
and I wanted to push it as far away from
my life but it's also given me so much
and for me to be back involved I I do
feel like it's it's just the way things
were meant to be to come full circle in
some way shape or form well it's it's
you realizing what needs to be done to
make sure that this circle could
actually be made full Brian leaf here on
the Rich Eisen show so let me ask you
this and I was gonna ask you a pac-12
question and if we have time I will do
we were talking at nauseam this week
about number one first round draft
choice quarterbacks
stardom throw them in there's sink or
swim certainly if you're an organization
that has not one of late you need to see
what you've gotten somebody right away
what is Erie philosophy that you have
Ryan from your perspective I think that
things have changed quite a bit I think
that the players that are being drafted
first into the NFL are much more
prepared than I ever was just when it
comes to dealing with the media dealing
with failure I think that we haven't
seen them what you would consider a
first-round bust at quarterback for
quite a while maybe rg3 and that Manziel
in there I mean Johnny was Chad dressed
real for it but I mean you're talking
about top five yeah let's say yeah let's
say that that I don't necessarily know
if it truly has happened in a while so
what I like to see is I'd like to see
the guys get the opportunities if
they're ready the idea that I planted
here a while ago when I was here talking
about you know the Cleveland Browns and
not wanting to go there you know I don't
know what that's gonna you hear you're
up on them like a six or eight game
eight i season this year yeah I am well
Jarvis Landry and if obviously whatever
Josh Gordon is coming to grips with
successfully if he's out there David and
joko I mean these are all physical
people with serious business decisions
created on behalf of the people they're
going towards you know Chubb and Carlos
Hyde and Duke Johnson the offensive line
I mean and then there's the defensive
side of the ball Miles Garrett not they
have playmakers they do spot Jabril
Peppers they got playmakers everywhere
they should they should they should be
they should have been before - at some
points I think this is a systemic the
fact they brought in John Dorsey I think
is a huge step forward I wouldn't be
surprised if we see it but if we do see
a step forward it's not going to be with
Baker Mayfield at the quarterback
position it's gonna be because of Tyrod
Taylor and and if they are where you get
where you say and they get to six or
eight wins the Baker Mayfield is not
gonna be the one getting in the games
then because it that's gonna be enough
wins to probably say Hugh Jackson's job
I know that and then but then at some
point they're gonna have to transition
to Baker
I feel he's number one overall Ryan so
not the Green Bay Packers right I don't
believe so I have they can't they I
don't know if they have it in them to to
do what they're gonna try to do and
that's allow the starter to be the
quarterback and have the rookie learn
you know that's there's two different
organizations there it worked out and it
was combustible in almost a chaotic
situation yes right Favre left in all
the process so I mean it's it's
interesting that's why it plays out the
NFL's is is fun fun to be a part of I'm
more particularly I'm can't wait for
college football to start it starts next
Thursday a week from today yes it does
next Thursday I've got there so there's
five games a pac-12 network has weber
state Utah which games are you calling
for the pac-12 network I'm doing a
couple Washington State games
they're non-conference more importantly
the the first game is against San Jose
State which will be the first home game
mat in Pullman since the passing of
Tyler Hill in ski and most likely
they're gonna do something to remember
him by in that first play and what an
honor is it gonna be to be on the call
for that moment what do you think can
you reveal what what they might do this
I assume it'll be something similar and
what's been talked about as possibly
doing the missing man formation like for
Sean Taylor yes yeah Nebraska did for
their punter mmm-hmm I hope so I think
that it that would be a representative
of what they felt for Tyler and I think
it would be it's gonna be an emotional
for me too you're getting emotional here
yeah it's gonna be emotional for me to
be on the call and that's where the
emotion switched when I was speaking to
Washington where it kind of turned from
the fact that I was speaking to you know
those those mangy dogs and hurtful you
know it was about that even though they
did that even though they were more the
W you know they wear the purple
I don't want anybody anywhere ever to
feel like they're not worth it at any
point because this human existence is so
important it's just it's so precious and
now that I have a child and just the
things I've been through in the
understanding of what's important in
life that can never we got to change the
stigma so that nothing like that ever
happens again well enjoy those
those road trips Ryan and let's see how
you can work us into your schedule I
love it your very busy schedule always
enjoy having you here man thanks guys
always enjoyed you got it so Ryan Leaf
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience